an earthquake that has struck
Indonesia's main island of java killing
at least 46 people government officials
say hundreds more have been injured the
Quake damaged many structures and
triggered landslides in the capital of
Jakarta thousands evacuated into the
streets after high-rise buildings
started swaying
and we're joined Now by DW's preeta
kusuma putri who is in our studio in the
capital Jakarta pray to what more can
you tell us about the quake
yeah we remain a lot about the
casualties uh but the latest data we got
so far at least 25 people have been
killed and dozens are injured and it is
confirmed that the epicenter of the
earthquake in tiander in West Jaffa they
also hits the Jakarta the capital and
its surrounding was on land and that is
why the meteorology and climatology and
geophysics agency said that it doesn't
have the possibility of the tsunami but
they also stated that there had been 25
aftershocks you know after the
earthquake happened and um yeah uh I'm
standing here
um a hundred kilometers from the
epicenter but the Quake was so strong
people are rushed out from the
apartments from the offices and now
situations are more under control here
in capital but you know they're into
anjour the epicenter you can see like so
many buildings are collapsed people are
you know being taken away to the
hospitals right I wanted to ask you
about the damage how extensive is it
yeah as you can see
um so many buildings are collapsed just
to give you a clear idea about the
epicenter of the earthquake it's
basically located in a rural area where
you know people are not um build their
houses with a you know with a proper
techniques so many buildings are you
know based uh by the you know the woods
and only like a bricks so it could
easily collapse when the earthquake like
this happened and that also includes the
hospitals there they are not you know
they're not so many hospitals there so
now um the doctors
um trying their best to
um you know save the the the victims but
you can see like so many uh passion
patients are you know put outside the
hospitals just in case the you know the
aftershocks happens again and yeah
they're still keeping a close watch on
this
Freda thank you very much our
correspondent Prieta kusuma putri there
in Jakarta
[Music]